if someone is feeling shy they don't  have a lot of social confidence how can  someone overcome that when we're talking  to shy people what we often tell them to  do is say one extra sentence so the  normal thing is that'll be 592 you give  them your thing but something is in your  head there's a magazine cover there the  weather is hot they have a nice earring  or something say one extra thing lower  that filter of what would be acceptable  to say you think that the things that  you have to say are such crap that you  communicate that with every fiber of  your being and so once you're saying  them then we have to teach okay say with  your chest don't Trail off at the end of  sentences do not let someone cut you off  until you hit a period it's not about  being a conversational bully it's about  learning to take up conversational space  in a way that is assertive